j'accueille maintenant jean michel jarre
jean michel jarre mesdames messieurs qui
vous appelle encore jamie mamère
quelques-uns quelques intimes
ouais ça se perd un peu j'espère un peu
appliquez votre mère bah ouais mais ça
fait plaisir tiré que vous avez toujours
les cheveux longs et finalement ça
revient à la mode votre musique
bah oui c'est ça il faut être patient il
faut être patient fois en matinée
surtout et obstiné ça finit par revenir
à la mode alors parler de vous
elle est née à lyon oui et justement
quand on étudie votre vie on découvre
que tout ça n'est pas venu par hasard
puisque votre grand père qui était
ingénieur au service des eaux de lillion
a été l'inventeur de la console de
mixage
oui c'est vrai frida 1n 1d invente un
des inventeurs à radio lyon de la
console de mixage et il a inventé aussi
le tourne-disque dépasse le fameux pick
up a été inventé par le grand père de
jean-michel jarre pense évidemment ça
allait moins 20 des voix qui viendra
dans mall jeu
c'est bizarre la vie donc très tôt jean
michel jarre fait chaud en contact avec
la technologie façon un peu bouts de
ficelle et bidouillages peu géo
trouvetou d'une certaine façon à 6 7 ans
vous vous mettez au piano donc voilà
tout ça progresse
votre père évidemment c'est le grand
compositeur maurice jarre 1
mais quand vous mettez au piano à l'âge
de 6-7 ans il est parti il est parti de
la maison
il est parti quand vous aviez cinq ans
il ya sans doute une espèce d'héritage
génétique j'imagine parce que oui c'est
pas enfin j'ai eu effectivement grandi à
s'est passé assez loin de lui aussi bien
effectivement que physiquement puisqu'il
est parti aux états unis il est revu
quand j'avais 20 ans voilà l'une a fait
une carrière extraordinaire aux états
unis il a écrit connais tous chanson de
lara docteur jivago lawrence d'arabie et
caetera et il est parti en vous laissant
votre mère et vous en vous abandonnant
d'une certaine façon vous laissant sans
un sou la moitié des droits dollar à la
chanson de lara sont revenus à dany
saval quand il a rompu avec elle mais
votre mère et vous vous n'avez rien eu
et vous dites souvent des refoulements
vous dit j'avais un nom qui signifie
argent mais ma mère faisait des tricots
pour gagner sa vie est d'ailleurs après
quelques années plus tard quand vous
avez habité à paris il avait un stand
opus donc une femme modeste
c'est très étonnant de savoir que le
fils de maurice jarre vivait dans un
deux pièces à issy les moulineaux
quand logis du patin à roulettes dans
l'appartement il va un couloir l
appartement était tellement petit s'est
terminée dans les chiottes et vous avez
toujours les cicatrices
comment il sait ça je ne sais pas
comment il serait si tous les décès des
amateurs les chasseurs des patins à
roulettes avec les petits
et c'est pour ça que philippe candeloro
vous acquitter oui c'est ça très tôt ça
va pas durer longtemps avec en vélo
alors votre maire si une femme
remarquable c'est une femme qui n'avait
d'autre ressource que sa pension de
déportés car elle avait eu un
comportement exemplaire pendant la
guerre france pejot l'été à ravensbrück
non pas seulement des portes une jeune
résidente mme amos a déploré l'incident
elle a été déportée parce qu'elles
étaient résistantes jeudi pour elle et
pour moi aussi mais voilà alors
évidemment quand on regarde tout ça le
grand-père la console de mixage le thé
pas le père maurice jarre le piano à
l'âge de 6 ans et alors autre chose
aussi c'est que à l'âge de 10 ans votre
mère avait connu en prison la patronne
du chat qui pêche le chat qui pêche
c'était un club d'un club de jazz où
vous avez vu très jeune à l'âge de 10
ans davy chet baker donne tsheri qui
était le père de nenê de eagle eye
cherry
vous avez vu colts rennes donc voilà
comme ça c'est oui c'est vrai pour
l'anniversaire de l'innovant tout à fait
tout à fait par hasard comme ça je
traînais dans cette boîte obtenu par en
fait la une des meilleures amies de ma
mère à chet baker m'a mis sur le piano
comme ça il m'a joué de la trompette
pour mon anniversaire et je sens encore
même encore aujourd'hui quand j'en parle
le souffle de la la trompette dans le
sur le vent très bons souvenirs je
savais pas du tout qui c'était et ce qui
est bizarre c'est que cette période je
n'ai que des souvenirs en noir et blanc
le jazz en fait finalement et le jazz et
noir et blanc il devrait scellier est en
fait c'est drôle que tout c'est tous ces
souvenirs sont quand j'y pense
aujourd'hui me reviennent en noir et
blanc
alors voilà bon qui après dans les
années 60 vous découvrez le rock'n'roll
elvis presley wright charles la musique
instrumentale avec les shadows apache et
un jour vous assister à un concert de
daniel logan et les pirates
et là vous dites je veux faire la même
chose vous créez un groupe qui s'appelle
les mystères 4g est vendu votre train
électrique pour acheter une guitare un
magnétophone
c'est vrai à drouot le deuxième groupe
s'appelait 2 bin ce qui violait les
poubelles et là vous commencez à
trafiquer le
un peu de bide ou de sons sur votre
magnétophone et après trois ou quatre
ans de rock
je vais quand même battu les haricots
rouges au tremplin du salon de l'enfance
c'est à un autre chose aussi c'est que
je suis parti en angleterre avec ce
groupe et que on a joué dans un groupe
dans un club qui a beaucoup fait parler
de lui à l'époque des années 60 qui est
des marquis club où on était plusieurs
groupes a animé la soirée et le groupe
qui passaient après c'était un petit
groupe dans lequel yves eric clapton et
jeff beck crois et qui a été lié à
cordes après allez iab et j'étais un bon
souvenir for your love
les riders exactement alors donc voilà
le rock bon je vous fatiguer un peu vous
découvrez la musique électronique
à la fin des années 60 68 69 au groupe
de recherches musicales de pierre
schaeffer et là vous commencez c'est
donc vachement moi je m'entoure quoi il
ya longtemps tous les cas vous commencez
à faire des montages de bandes et des
sampling comme comme on dit maintenant
la synthèse électronique évidemment la
théorie c'est d'abord des leçons sous la
forme de textures de couleurs plus que
de notes c'est ça c'est vrai c'est que
pierre schefer en fait à inventer c'est
un des personnages qui a révolutionné
dit dans le xxème siècle c'est vraiment
aujourd'hui si la techno la house music
tout toute l'électronique on connaît
aujourd'hui exister grâce à lui rex est
vraiment chez sphère qui a tout inventé
ces prêts en partie de paris partie de
la france est alors à cette époque là
vous piquez les clés le soir du groupe
de recherches musicales grm et vous
allez bosser la nuit sur un sur un
premier disque qui s'appelle la cage
vendu à 117 exemplaire quidam france et
avoir encore oxygène et le stock a été
détruit par pathé marconi quoi ya pas
grand chose a détruit en même temps
l'onu m
ça s'est jamais vendu qua non mais
c'était l'époque où il y avait un
certain nombre de gens comme gérard
manset claude michel schönberg comme
julien clerc ou s'ils ont dû tous chez
pathé et les disques se lançait souvent
par la fenêtre et en face de chez
d'europe 1 est en fait quand on lancer
un disque on lançait plus tôt par la
fenêtre
quel sérieux mais l'artiste alors en 71
vous êtes le plus jeune musicien avoir
été représenté à l'opéra vous faites un
truc ça tél ah ouais enfin hors dire
lumière en hébreu c'est que c'était il
faut remettre dans le contexte est cette
telle époque d'après 68 où il ya eu une
époque un peu doré comme ça où tous
mélangés on pourrait aussi bien du rock
du jazz du classique lectronique un peu
dans des endroits un peu bizarre et
c'est vrai que les chroniques à l'opéra
cette épreuve c'était l'ouverture de
l'opéra après le camp tchaga là on ne
l'a pas le plafond de l'opéra donc avec
la réouverture et c'était le spectacle
concert de d'ouverture et c'est une
chose qu'on a qu'on a finalement peu
revu cette espèce de moments un peu
magique de l'après-68 trou dans trois
quatre ans il ya eu comme ça d un
mélange de genre ou finalement examen
qui dit oui mais je dis oui parce
qu'elle mois à 8 ans j'étais j'allais
des parents très polis culé et gt gt au
secours au secours rouge et j'étais au
comité gavroche révolutionnaire je n'ai
pas le voyage
mais il y avait un côté tout le monde se
parlait dans la rue tout montrer des
trucs assez duré trois quatre ans comme
ça les gens en parlent tous deux 68 mon
papa de 72 en fête les 68 72 il trois
quatre ans comme ça qui était aveugle et
gazoline si voilà exactement